rar I'm
good, I'm good, how much I've been saved
I'm talking about Berg.
I'll never forgive those guys who tend to
be buyers. I've been thinking about this for a long time, but 1009-chan is tough in a bad way.
I feel like I'm suddenly thundering before preparation and my voice is different
.
I
want you to answer the question to
make sure that it's really a shame if it's real.
You should understand the Japanese system. There are three choices such as dependence
. The
memory disappeared due to
petrification. 1 The
answer is 10 billion sheets.
It's an estimated logical dissolution.
no 9 It's over 1000 sheets
I don't know above that ok
It's my job after enough
[Applause]
I had a commemorative party to break through 5000 sheets before soybeans, but I'm sorry I don't remember because cd is no longer the mainstay
Then, at the end, if you can say this number,
you can believe it. This line Miya-chan, if it's a solid number quiz, that calculation What kind of Fermi,
hey,
3 years old.